the next generation of russian foot
soldiers guarding the eternal flame in
the city of yekaterinburg growing up
with the echo of for the motherland for
victory in their ears
and here's their inspiration if they
make it to yukatarinburg's military
academy which has given russia this
propaganda hit to fit the times
on the streets of the city the parade
rehearsal is not quite so slick and the
rain doesn't help
the military hardware that's not on the
battlefield prepped for display in 28
russian cities some with pictures of the
boys lost so far in ukraine pasted on
their sides
how many more of those pictures will
there be
it's hard to overstate the almost sacred
importance of victory day here and how
much it's bound up with the notion of
sacrifice the millions of lives lost in
world war ii so whatever victory it is
that vladimir putin declares on monday
that idea of sacrifice the cost to the
russian people will also be there
unfortunate but necessary for whatever
greater goal it is that he declares
igor is worried that ukraine is turning
into a broader conflict between russia
and nato but he thinks that the russian
people will get on board
[Music]
but he doesn't speak for everyone
nadeshdo saifudinova sewed up her mouth
in protest at the censorship the fact
she says that the russian people are
already muted
she was detained by police then taken by
medics against her will first to a
hospital and then a psychiatric clinic
now she has two court cases coming up
for discrediting the armed forces
a social worker is due to visit to
assess whether she's fit to look after
her boy tim faye that's the cost of
protest here
and yet yekaterinburg had a reputation
as a liberal place
the yeltsin center which opened in 2017
as a temple to the seeds of democracy
planted by vladimir putin's predecessor
boris yeltsin in the 1990s
when he was resigning yes
take care of russia
the 31st of december 1999. the freedoms
the people won then at risk of being
lost again in the grand sweep of russian
history with all of it seismic change
and its colossal bloodshed
outside we meet the former mayor evgeny
roizman he's also facing charges for
speaking out but it's not stopping him
somewhere
m
[Music]
across the river is a church on the spot
where the last tsar and his family were
murdered by the bolsheviks
[Music]
now the flags of donbass fly there
alongside the zed
the symbol of a new and dangerous
chapter in a history written in blood
diana magnay sky news yekaterinburg
russia